because the world changes at such a fast
pace right now
if you're not curious you are going to
feel and fall behind
and maintain that curiosity and and and
challenge yourself to to keep
being curious um and learning more and
putting yourself in situations that are
unpredictable and uncertain
dr anushka pachava thank you for joining
me today all the way from london how are
you
hey michael doing well how are you doing
uh now that we're talking i'm doing
fantastic because i'm so excited to hear
all about your journey
all about your insights into the the the
intersection between innovation
and and medicine i think that what we're
seeing now obviously with 2020 but you
know really this past
decade or so we've seen a surgeons of
understanding that technology is not
just for social media it's not just for
you know a better speakers in our car
but it's really in our everyday things
and we're seeing
lives transform through the integration
of these two fields
so you're you know you've been in the
media medical field for for quite some
time but more importantly than that
you've been an
advisor to the united an expert advisor
to the united nations
nations on artificial intelligence and
blockchain you've done all sorts of
really cool stuff
uh today with a cvs company and i'm
gonna stop talking here and i would love
to hear from you
who are you how do you get into medicine
and how do you then transition to the
world of technology
what a great question um who am i um
well as he says
i'm adopted by training i actually
started off doing biochemistry
undergrad school went down the kind of
american pathway of doing an undergrad
and then a post grad
and did my post grad in medicine trained
at the university of cambridge so a very
theoretical course we had
my best memories we had bodies that we
got to dissect on a weekly basis for the
first two years
and that body became your friend um so i
remember having friday afternoons
friday afternoons in the dissection lab
with me and my body um
so to speak and uh and then no doubt
after that trained in surgery and then
radiology just from the
interest of the human pathology and the
side of you know
what's in this body and what could go
wrong with this body and how we can fix
it
um and yeah so i trained out in uh uk
and the us
uh very different health systems one's a
single-payer government-led system
um the uk is and the state is a
multi-payer
complex quite challenging environment um
and then i decided after doing all of
that
that i wanted to go to the dark of the
dark side and work in health insurance
instead
um the reason being there was there's no
blood and health insurance and i
realized
after seven years in medicine i didn't
actually like blood or sick people
i love that tell me a little bit about
your
your your experience as a doctor what
would have been some of the most you
know
exhilarating parts and and possibly the
challenging things that myself who
probably won't be a doctor in my
lifetime
but who knows what what am i missing out
on
wow what are you missing out on so
you're missing out on camaraderie
i don't think i've ever worked or lived
in a place like a hospital which has so
much karate behind it that teen spirit
that everyone's in it together no matter
how long your hours were
up to 80 hours a week at times um you're
missing out on
um the exhilaration that you get from
helping someone or
saving a life um you know those small
things that you do for someone that
really has a positive impact on their
life and you can see it straight up
or you see it at a follow-up appointment
i remember working in a e in trauma
and actually feeling from the heart that
you were truly saving someone's life
um you're missing out on a lot of
intellectual stimulation that medicine
gives you because you're constantly
problem solving between
different parts of the body different
human psychologies
different um environments um trying to
put the puzzle together so to speak to
work out and
diagnose um i remember watching dr house
when i was younger and thinking
that's why i want to do medicine um but
you're not missing out on the
bureaucracy
and the challenges that you know i've
seen our workers in healthcare now face
with cover 19 and
you know big thanks to all of them um
going through what they are on the front
line
you're not missing out on the resource
allocation decision making which is very
very challenging
not only to us as as physicians but also
in terms of moral
compass right um you're not missing out
the politics of any healthcare system
via the us or the uk it's the same
politics of underfunded healthcare
that we're now unfortunately realizing
has significant consequences for
human life um you know in 100 percent
i have to say that dr anushka because
the reason i was asking this is because
uh there is something that's quite
surprising about your history
i want you to take me back all the way
to the age of 18 and
you compete in the london marathon you
complete the laundry marathon i believe
you're the second youngest
to complete it at the time i'm sure
there's been younger sins but at the
time i was the
second youngest i think my brother's the
third youngest so he's uh
just under 11 months older than me um so
he did it when he was 18. i went back a
year later broke his record
also broke my knee at the same time
unbelievable so then so the reason i was
asking about you know the doctor is
because obviously then you
it's quite ironic to go in and fracture
your knee and i have to say actually
that i
i have a quite a similar experience i
believe i was 19 when i did the
a lot marathon which is in the desert of
israel it's with the dunes
and i was very much under prepared i did
it in four hours and 40 minutes and
there's this
and there's a picture that i love of me
finishing i'm crying
from pain but from happiness because
they were both together because i also
have a
a very large injury with my knee that
i'm facing until today
but at the end it's about the finishing
we don't care about that injury in the
in the real time right
agree agree michael i guess you you
could see your tears when you finished
because you were in a hot country
um it was raining in london so i was
crying and people thought it was just
the rain falling down on my cheeks
i love that okay so you're in medicine
for for six seven years and then you
you also begin thinking about technology
and innovation and how people
consume uh you know digital and physical
health care
and you have some really interesting
insights in that regard so how do you
become
sort of like this go to advisor and
expert on these topics
so you're you're um right in terms of
the the blend right now we see between
for digital but before we get there
um the reason i went into technology and
technology and healthcare is because i
was working in radiology and radiology
is very
autonomous as a field we're looking at
images day in day out and i remember
being sat on night shifts and being told
by my bosses at the time
you have to report every single x-ray in
the bank all of them overnight by the
next morning
and you know you're sitting there in a
dark room it's the middle of the night
you're fatigued it's probably your sixth
or seventh night shifts in a row
your seniors somewhere in the department
but you don't know where you're
you know you're clutching at straws
looking at scan after scan of the scan
and you know we all experience this
right now with screen fatigue where
your eyes start to close or they start
to burn and you see a bit blurry
that was the the life for me and i
remember thinking there must be a better
way of doing this there must be an image
reader
you know which is now coming into the
fields of a.i
or artificial artificial intelligence or
augmented intelligence and healthcare
whereby something scans it before i scan
it
and picks up what i could potentially
miss in terms of human error
and that's when i started thinking about
technology um and
working in a hospital central london
hospital in the nhs where
booking and scheduling was a hassle
canceling appointments for a hassle
accessing consumers records you know
from a different
hospital system to another hospital
system was a hassle right
exercise accessing primary care records
in in the secondary care system was a
hassle
i began to think that there must be
technological solutions out there that
can fix this in terms of you know
perpetuating data fluidity but also
increasing accuracy and
and allowing physicians like myself to
function more at top of the license
instead of the
administrative or bureaucratic tasks and
that is what
would really span my interest in in
health technology
um you asked me how i ended up there um
well i got really bored
with studying for radiology exams um i
decided that black and white wasn't
really for me
anymore and unfortunately all the
radiology scans are in black and white
um and i started teaching myself how to
code um and that is what
got me really interested in technology
um the logic behind python coding
um and and i guess the satisfaction
behind being able to automate
even basic things like your tax return
or counting your your weekly and monthly
spends
uh really really helped um drive my
interest in the field
so i i really want to you know stop here
on this point for just a little bit
because i think
that it's a fascinating journey of any
person that
you know becomes an expert in one field
and you know you could write out that
expertise forever
pretty much right i mean you could be
continue to be a radiologist it's it's
incredibly difficult
to get to the position that you were at
and obviously also did
an mba in london and neo is studying in
cambridge and
so you still decide that you have this
urgency to go and continue innovating
and
learning the cutting edge technologies
in you in your free time you
teach yourself python and machine
learning what was that experience like
did you
have any resistance with that was it you
know were there any
big challenges along the way and
particularly for people who are
considering
teaching themselves or you know or
taking whatever field they studied and
now
putting it together with uh with
programming what would you say to that
i'd say go go for it my one principle in
life is be curious
um and if you are curious and you
maintain curiosity
you'll never feel like you're falling
behind um but the barriers as you speak
of michael are definitely
still in existence so i come from a very
strong indian family
um my parents were you know people who
had a single career they were physicians
and surgeons their whole life
and for them to understand what a
portfolio career was
and the fact that people do now have
portfolio careers you do three days in
one job two days in another you might
have your own startup
you might have what people call side
hustles some people are influencers in
their free time
and that was very new thinking when i
went into it um
and almost um considered rebellious
thinking um now is becoming more and
more the norm and i think for me
um breaking down those barriers of what
is culturally acceptable
um understanding for myself that
why did i believe that i had to work
five days a week at a specific location
if it wasn't bringing happiness to me
and digging deep into that in myself
what were my reasons and challenging my
own
um i guess psyche and my own values
really helps um and then like i say
going back to the point curiosity if
you've got curiosity in you
use it challenge channel it build that
energy
um and you you then you realize you get
to meet so many people like i've met you
and you get to meet like you know other
people who are doing the same thing and
it becomes more of the norm and more
acceptable
right and and there's something
addictive in it as well there's
something addictive in
you know discovering something new
starting to get good at it saying
you know getting thrown off track and
saying okay like wow
i was i'm an expert in one field and now
i know nothing in this other field and
it's so exciting because it's like
back to first grade and you have those
like really quick milestones where you
get there and i think that you know if
programming by itself is you know
there's a big learning curve once you
get on once you get into the habit and
you learn how to learn it it becomes
really really fantastic talk to me a
little bit about you know this this term
that you've coined
i think three and a half years ago about
this balance between digital and
physical healthcare
really um came it came to my mind
three and a half years ago but really
michael being honest it's become so
normal
um as a result of covert and people will
tell you like you know you know
was it your cto or your cio or your ceo
that
that resulted in the digital
transformation that happened in your
sector or your business and everyone now
says it was neither
or none of the three it was actually
covered and the same is true for health
care
whereby before um consumers or patients
as they're known in healthcare wanted
that physical
ecosystem they wanted to go to the
hospital they felt they needed to be
touched and examined and have that
physical contact with a professional in
order to be diagnosed
now more and more we're seeing consumers
resisting
going to physical clinics they don't
want to be in a contaminated environment
they don't want to put themselves or
their family members at risk but yet
they still need and seek healthcare so
how do we balance that
and it's that blender for digital what
can we take out of the physical
environment is it
you know video consultations that have
been around for quite a few years now
and have seen a huge i think 300 to 500
uplift with most of the providers
over covered or is it more can we do
diagnostics in in the digital space
i know people who are building um
retinal cameras on your phone
so you could do eye appointments at home
instead of go to the eye
uh clinic or the optician i know people
who
can diagnose your pulse your perfusion
and your oxygen saturation just from a
selfie
um it's a company that was based in
israel i'm sure you know of them um the
bin a.i guys and
you know it's amazing what technology
can do and
now consumers have got used to the zooms
and being online and being on screens
and embracing technology
we can accentuate the the speed we were
working at to get technology into
healthcare
right no i think that i think that what
you're saying is completely true are
there some other you know things that
i as you know as a spectator in in this
field
i'm not even aware of where we are
actually headed so a lot of the things
that we're talking here you know i
truly expect to come to the market you
know in you know max five years right i
mean things have been
advancing so quickly the number of
startups that i'm seeing
in the investment space that are dealing
with these things it's exponential
compared to what it was you know it's by
a factor like 10
compared to what it was just a few years
ago because i think we realized that now
it's not just that
consumers are willing to accept it but
the doctors are also in it and the
hospitals are also in it so you have
this two-sided marketplace that
is willing to cooperate what other some
large-scale things are we going to see
do you think in healthcare
that i might not even be thinking of in
terms of you know other acceptance or
adoption
you're right it has to be a two-sided
coin so the health system needs to
deploy implement and accept it before
before it gets to the consumer
um and i think it's both sides driving
change at the moment which is which is
fantastic and that's why you're seeing
the catalyst
the interesting spaces i've been looking
at is healthcare at home so how do you
put the hospital in someone's house
um we've had virtual clinics for a long
time we've had virtual waiting rooms so
a company called humor you previously
known as meadowpad in the uk have built
virtual covered waiting rooms
whereby if you're diagnosed with kovid
you remain at home you check into your
virtual waiting room every day
um your work virtual ward so to speak
and the doctor visits you
with other cover patients in your
virtual ward you've got the use of alexa
alexa can be your friend think about all
these people that are lonely how do we
use voice to make them feel like they
have a companion
right right and how do we have the
elderly how do we
how do we put technology in a home so
that an elderly person living on their
own can be looked after is it the alexa
that
you know or the google um device that
tells them this is time for your
medication please take your medication
or is it
the mirror that checks their blood
pressure and their perfusion when they
look
at it or is it the sofa tv um and the
sofa in front of the tv that has sensors
so that if a member of
that sitting on the sofa falls off it
triggers an electric alarm
or is it the tv itself that acts as you
know not as
just a tv but as a consultation platform
which allows you to access healthcare
you know dial into your physiotherapy
what is it
um and you're starting to see loads of
technologies come into that space what
you aren't seeing is one
provider integrator into right
healthcare at home
but you are starting to see little plays
so you're seeing the amazons you've seen
the apples trying to break into
healthcare
you're seeing samsung with several
devices that can potentiate healthcare
at home
um you've always had you know tvs that
access and work with the internet
um it's all a really really fascinating
space and one of the recent things i i
heard of was um
it was impressive it's a smart fridge
that tells you
when you're running out of food and
right
and not only when you're running out of
food but also here's the here's the food
that you have in your fridge do you want
a recipe to help you use what's in your
fridge already
how convenient is that 100
so now that we talk about all the things
that we can be really excited about and
that we
hopefully will see in the coming years
what is the problem perhaps the single
or two biggest challenges
that the health that the health care
system is facing today in adopting these
technologies because
a lot of them are almost ready right a
lot of them are are either you have a
lot of papers written on them
or you have companies that are actually
trying to create products out of those
papers
why what's still holding us back so it's
great michael having loads of devices
that take your data but unless that data
all sits in one place and there's
fluidity
that then your physician can access your
physician can't act
or take in that data and derive insights
so even your apple watches we all walk
around wearing them but that device and
that data are still really only looked
at by me how do i get that into my
health records how do i get that into my
insurance premiums even you know um
that's not connected
so the interoperability of multivariate
devices
um and the data from those devices
flowing into the healthcare system is a
huge
a huge um i guess concern in terms of
privacy
but also a huge um challenge in terms of
how do you break down those boundaries
so all that we're absorbing from from
the technologies we're using is useful
to protect us in the long term
um so that's my first challenge um my
second challenge would be around
the differentiation between consumer and
patient um
because i'm not a patient until i'm sick
in my head
but does the health system still see me
as a patient when i'm well
um and it's that blurring of lines
between being proactive and reactive and
at the moment the health systems around
the world are very reactive to sickness
very reactive right so how do they be
more proactive how do we shift towards
prevention
and how do we shift the psychology of
not only physicians and healthcare
practitioners but also
consumers or patients towards you are
responsible for my health when i'm well
as much as you are when i'm sick and i
think that's a huge challenge
right i think that you're completely
right i think that one of the things
that i've been observing is that
explainability is becoming easier and
you
and you know we have here a two-sided
market not just you know with
the with the you know companies are
providing some stars but you also have
two-sided market between
the people that are innovating and then
the people that are authorizing this
innovation
and i'm thinking all the way no to today
where potentially i'll be the first
person in line to get a chip
to be installed in my palm that will
constantly monitor my blood tests i'd
love that that would be awesome
but i imagine that while i'm the first
person in line there's gonna be about a
hundred people before me that are going
to be resistant to that
for for sometimes very good reasons
sometimes reasons that maybe they don't
understand fully and i'm extremely
curious to see how
we're going to find this interesting
integration between the innovators and
the regulators and i think people
in your field that have a good
understanding of both
not just people that like technology but
you're learning python you're learning
machine learning
you're you're active with investments
and with with the startups i think
that's exactly what we need so i'm
extremely hopeful
at this point after this conversation
for for what we're headed thank you very
much dr anushka and before we leave
i have to ask you for the most important
question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself oh wow
um so just to go on your final point
michael i agree i'm very excited to see
how innovators physicians
consumers and the regulators can work
better and more effectively together and
i think big tech companies have a role
to play in terms of data privacy infosec
and ensuring that consumers feel safe
allowing um what we've talked about to
actually
occur in in in the world right um three
words to describe myself i was trying to
buy myself some time there
um i'm going to go with abc so a i say
one of my close principles to my heart
is being authentic so authenticity
counts above everything else
um b i'd say is be bold and it's a bold
and what you do but bold and challenging
your own your own
values your own falafel philosophies
because we've all grown up in different
environments
i grew up in saudi arabia for example my
values were based on my ecosystem at the
time but since then i've lived in
several different
geographies so be bold to to challenge
why you think and feel
um and see things the way you do um and
your perspective
and see i think i've touched on earlier
in our talk curiosity because the world
changes at such a fast pace right now
if you're not curious you are going to
feel and fall behind
and maintain that curiosity and and
challenge yourself to keep
being curious um and learning more and
putting yourself in situations that are
unpredictable and uncertain
um like the pandemic because that will
serve you well
i love that dr anushka thank you so so
much this was really wonderful
and stay safe and stay healthy pleasure
to meet you michael and take care
thank you